hey youtubers it's Charlie this week's
supernatural brought back an old friend
to make things right and played off a
plot point set off all the way back in
season eight it also let us know that
Dean is the world's worst ghost
whisperer did he learn nothing from
ghostfacers
I'll also be including some bits about
the spin-off show tribes after I
speechify in this episode and I've got
some details about the special fandom
oscars and then I'm gonna do this
weekend it's just gonna be a fun way to
riff on the regular Oscars only just for
science fiction and fantasy stuff so be
sure to subscribe to participate I'll be
posting a video soon that'll explain how
that's all gonna work so for this
episode let's do our top five moments
and then I'll do my review and then I'll
talk about the spin-off show so careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet but number five Castiel vs.
Bartholomew sure he had the B storyline
this week but it was a really nice twist
to make the evilish angel Bartholomew
Castiel's former comrade-in-arms
if you hadn't seen it yet the whole
Raphael war they were talking about was
from season six which is on Netflix
right now but the whole exchange made it
seem like they were setting up Castiel
to become the new God either at the end
of this season or in season 10 not in
the way he was God during season 7 but a
newer wiser more benevolent leader with
a lot more city miles on him I don't
know about you guys but I totally wasn't
surprised when those other angels showed
up to follow him at the end of the
episode meet the newest angel faction in
the war for heaven let me know what you
think we should call him number 4 tiger
mom electrician so it was funny to see
her author her own escape via the
electrical panel and to see Sam's
reaction but based on the timeline I
feel like she would have at least tried
to escape a few times I mean she is
tiger mom she's not just gonna sit there
they didn't really acknowledge any
attempted breakouts but I think it's
implied that she was chained to the
opposite wall because she had tried to
escape so many times I mean if you're
smart enough to MacGyver a control panel
then you could probably pick a lock
number three tiger mom part 2 revenge of
the tiger mom I love this setup for her
killing Diamond L I knew he was working
with Crowley and he clearly got fruit
loops but I did not realize that he was
a demon until she stabbed him so for
most of that exchange I actually thought
that she was just gonna revenge murder
him number 2 Tran family reunion it had
been teased for the entire episode and
was a huge payoff to Crowley's lie that
he had killed her back in season 8 I
love that as dark as supernatural gets
it kind of takes some of the worst
things back
the big tease at the end though was that
Kevin's spirit is going to start to get
really twisted from staying on earth too
long
his mom acknowledges it and as happy as
the moment was I felt like there was
this really dark overtone and my number
one moment no surprise here Kevin is
back I separated this from the reunion
because it was the biggest surprise of
the episode I was a little blown away
that they've revealed him as the ghost
so quickly and at how quickly they
brushed over Sam killing him Kevin
seemed like he was totally over it and
just happy to carry on in his old role
sending them on missions albeit for a
slightly more personal one this time
bringing him back was such a huge thing
that I was surprised they didn't tease
any haunted bunker moments in previous
episodes but the good news is is that
until they fix heaven kevin is stuck on
earth so you'll know he'll be back in
another episode now it's your turn let
me know what was your favorite moment
and how else do you think that ghost
Kevin is going to help them this year
overall I gave the episode a solid
b-plus for paying off the two really
important plot points with the Kevin's
story and teasing a major shift in the
Castiel character and the war for heaven
bonus points for getting rid of
Bartholomew he was totally a dick more
to the Castiel story though I always
kind of viewed him as the conscience of
the show the one that always considers
the moral implications of what they're
doing so I think that Misha Collins did
a great job of showing with his
performance the Castiel totally
understands that he's probably going to
end up having to be God or at least the
leader of heaven again the factions are
really just the first step eventually
his will get bigger and regardless of
how it happens he'll be in charge I
think they're trying to imply though
that this time things will be better the
only things that I thought could have
been better were drawing out the Kevin
revealed till the end of the episode
instead of at the beginning and Dean
felt like he almost didn't belong in the
episode if they had dropped maybe five
of his lines Sam could have done this
whole mission by himself now let's talk
about some spin-off they have finally
cast the leads for tribes just like the
original there are two leads Lucian
lavis count and nathan bugh Zola they're
going to air a backdoor pilot episode on
April 29th as a regular supernatural
episode it will introduce the characters
and set up with the main series arc is
going to be the first season the show
will be centred in Chicago and it'll be
like a noir sh monster mafia crime drama
think of it like The Untouchables with
monsters or you could even compare it to
the way Joss Whedon's angel worked in
and around Los Angeles with all the
different monster and demon factions
here are some details about the
character
Lavis count will play Ennis Roth a
police officer whose fiance is killed in
a monster mafia turf war he dedicates
himself to ridding Chicago of monsters
his co-star buzolic will play David
Haden a shape-shifter from one of the
most powerful monster families who's
given up the life and has been living as
a human he'll team-up within us to help
him clean up the city like I said this
will all play out on that episode on
April 29th
remember fandom Oscars coming up this
weekend I'll try and post a video in the
next day or two kind of explaining how
that's gonna work right now click here
to get my latest supernatural video and
click here to learn all about the flesh
spin-off the Grant Gustin thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you